[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in case you didn't
know recently I was away on a 15 day
trip where I had little to no internet
but now I am back and excited to be
talking about boku no heroes season 3
the first few episodes have aired and we
can already tell that season 3 is going
to change everything when it comes to
this series as someone who has read the
manga I can tell you that the next few
arcs in the story are incredible and it
is at this point in the manga that I
really fell in love with the series this
is why I predict that season 3 of boku
no hero will be the best season yet just
wait and see I plan to make regular
videos discussing season 3 and the new
episodes as they come out so if you want
to stay tuned for that don't forget to
subscribe and Detroit smash that
notification bell these videos will not
include manga spoilers so anime only
fans are safe and I want to make sure
that these videos are as interactive as
possible so every week I'm going to
start a new thread on our Twitter and
Instagram accounts with an MH a question
of the week for this week's question I
got the idea from a comment I received
on one of our older boku no hero videos
Lord Muhammad is doing an art project
and requires designing a new character
and he decided to create a character
with a quirk so he asks if anyone has
any original quirk ideas for him I
thought that this was a really cool
concept so on Twitter and Instagram I
asked you to reply with your own unique
quirk ideas with the only rules being
the your quirk can't be an exact copy of
one that already exists and that it has
to have some rules and limitations so
that it's not ridiculously old P I got a
lot more responses than I expected and
some of them were truly awesome so I
will talk about those at the end of this
video and if you want to participate and
be featured in a future video feel free
to follow at anime uproar on Twitter and
Instagram and give me your input now
episode 39 the first episode of season 3
was primarily a recap episode that
showed the students two
some lighthearted endurance training as
they reminisce about what happened in
the story up to this point even though
this was a recap episode I found it
useful because it reminded us of the
major points in the personal development
of the characters the main conflict
between the characters and the most
important plot points in the story the
very end of episode 39 was also really
interesting and together with the
beginning of episode 40 it provided some
heavy foreshadowing about what's going
to happen next we clearly see that the
villains are about to make a major move
to start a new game to use sugar Aki's
terminology and here's the big thing
that I noticed it is heavily implied by
the timing and sequence of the scenes at
the end of episode 39 and at the
beginning of episode 40 that shigaraki
and the villains found out about the
location of the training camp from
Shigure Aki's master before the students
themselves knew about the location the
location was changed at the last minute
so that it would stay a secret and even
the students didn't know until they got
there but the villains still found out
which suggests that there might be a
mole or traitor inside the UA who is
leaking vital information to the
villains and the sequence of events
leading up to the arrival at the
training camp is different in the manga
and in the manga we do not see the
scenes in which she go rocky gets the
information about the camp's location
from his master in the same way if the
shigaraki anime scenes are taking place
around the same time as Eraserhead and
the blood hero are discussing the
training camp and how the location has
to be changed and how even the students
don't know about it only the upper
management does and this does seem to be
the case because right after that scene
we see the scene in which cigar Aki
seems to learn about the location of the
camp and begins to put his own plan into
motion then this means that most likely
none of the students is the you a trader
the students would not have known about
the location of the camp when the
villains learned about it only the upper
management of you a new so one of them
would have to be the trader if you want
to know the most popular theories about
the UA traders secret identity including
my own theory which is that the trader
is not a student but indeed a member
the upper management check out my video
on the you a trader link in the
description we've always known that the
boku no hero anime adds in additional
scenes that are not included in the
manga at least not in the same exact way
sometimes these are filler scenes but
sometimes the additional scenes serve to
clarify the plot points and establish
the timeline I think that these
shigaraki scenes from the first two
episodes of season 3 could end up being
very important if it turns out that they
confirmed that the trader is not a
student but a member of the upper
management at UA these short scenes and
more scenes like them in the future
really could change everything that we
think we know about the story from the
manga alone definitely let me know what
you guys think down in the comments who
do you think is leaking information to
the villains is it a student or did
episode 39 and 40 just confirmed that
the leaker is a member of the upper you
a staff I'd love to hear your theories
in episode 40 the students finally
arrive at the training camp and we are
introduced for the first time to the
wild Pussycats and two of their four
members in particular Mandalay and pixie
Bob we also meet Koda the nephew of
Mandalay who has a tragic backstory his
parents were Pro heroes who sacrificed
their lives protecting innocent
civilians from a villain and even though
the world praised them for being heroes
Koda felt abandoned by his parents if
they chose to live their lives as normal
people they would still be there for him
but because they decided to become pro
heroes they ended up losing their lives
and abandoning Koda while he was still a
child this has led Koda to develop a
very negative view of Pro heroes in
general and the whole situation tells us
a great deal about the problems of the
hero Society Pro heroes are glorified
and praised in public but the truth is
not so simple risking your life every
day might seem glorious and brave to
outsiders but to your own family it is a
completely different situation actions
have consequences and if a pro hero
loses their life in battle the heroes
loved ones will still suffer no matter
how noble and heroic the hero's death
was with characters like Koda
also characters like shigaraki and stain
the legitimacy and logic behind the hero
society is being questioned we are
seeing below the shining facade of the
world of boku no hero and this adds
additional nuance and complexity to the
story which I really appreciate it's not
all black and white actions have
consequences and sometimes the good guys
lose and the bad guys win episode 40
leaves us with the knowledge that the
villains are about to make a big move a
move that the UA teachers and students
are not expecting and as I said before
this will lead us into some of the best
arcs and the entire series I've always
enjoyed the villain centric arcs the
most so I am super excited for this
season let me know if you're as excited
as I am down below and tell me if you
agree with me that season three is going
to be the best season yet and now let's
look at your ideas for a brand new quirk
within the world of boku no hero right
off the bat I can say that some of the
answers from the anime only fans we're
very close to already existing quirks
that appear in the manga so while I
can't count those I do appreciate the
input on Twitter caster for life says a
quirk that allows you to hear and read
other languages in your own language so
basically understanding any language
even if you never try to learn it
not much of a quirk when it comes to
fighting but I always like the idea of
being able to understand other languages
without needing to spend years studying
them so this would be a cool quirk in my
opinion maybe not for a pro hero but for
a diplomat or expert in international
law it's perfect super SIV wants to see
a quirk that allows you to stop time but
only for as long as you can hold your
breath the anime dude and lump King
pointed out that this is like cool doze
ability from Dragonball Z and it also
reminds me a bit of rolos Geass in cold
Geass but there's nothing wrong with
getting ideas from other anime worlds I
think that this concept of stopping or
maybe slowing down time for as long as
the character can hold their breath is a
fascinating one and I think a quirk like
that would be awesome in the world of
boku no hero especially if a villain
this would make for some pretty insane
plot twists so good job SIV definitely a
great idea for a quark simply rose says
Pizza vision the ability to shoot pizza
from your eyes hmm pretty pretty great
concept but here's my question can you
choose the toppings of the pizza before
shooting it out or is it like goat
cheese and extra anchovies on every
single one we need answers here rose
anime balls-deep wants to see a quirk
that allows you to talk to machines
somehow if this means like a hacking
quirk that allows you to break into and
control all sorts of tech devices then
that would indeed be super useful
especially in a world that is getting
more and more dependent on technology
anime recon wants to see a quirk that
allows you to counter any sort of attack
but it has a recharge time of 60 seconds
this reminds me a bit o melioidosis
ability full counter from seven deadly
sins and I do think that this would be a
very useful defensive quirk especially
in team battles a hero who works as part
of a hero team would be the ideal user
for this type of work
Francis Goyer says the ability to steal
your enemy's strength when attacking
them so the more you hit someone you
keep getting stronger and the enemy
keeps getting weaker this reminds me a
bit of bonds ability snatched from the
seven deadly sins and I do think that
such a quirk would be very cool because
it makes it difficult to fight the enemy
the more you attack the stronger the
enemy gets so you have to come up with a
different strategy to win without
getting into spoilers a hero character
in the manga does have a sort of similar
quirk Mega aka mega anime openings wants
to see a quirk that allows the user to
create a custom illusion that works
within a 5 meter radius the idea of
creating illusions was mentioned by a
few of you guys and I think that it
would be an amazing quirk it is similar
to Lorenzo Ilsa Reese's Geass in the
reign of the darkness manga spin-off and
I think that a quirk like this could be
used with great effectiveness in the
boku no hero story there is so much
potential for manipulation and crazy
plot twists with a quirk like that good
stuff mega my boy mystique Ren Axia
wants a quirk that would allow the user
to make good YouTube videos well you can
have that quirk all you
bro as long as I can get the quark that
lets you make insanely popular videos
that are not even good come to think of
it I'm pretty sure that the Paul
brothers already have that exact quirk
over on Instagram fairytale lover 1 5 4
49 wants to see a mind-reading quirk
that allows the user to predict the
opponent's next move but only one move
at a time so you can't read all of your
opponent's plans all at once this quirk
would be extremely useful in battle
obviously since the user would always be
one step ahead but using the correct too
often would put a strain on the body and
eventually lead to the user passing out
this one reminds me of Bismarck waltz
teens Geass from Code Geass and yeah I
know I talked about coal Geass a lot but
I'm a big fan and Bismarck is able to
see into the future but only for a few
seconds and that allows him to predict
his opponent's moves in battle
definitely a great idea that would make
for some excellent fight scenes as
everyone struggles to figure out how to
beat someone who is always one step
ahead Kwon gritch 9 also on Instagram
wants to see a camouflage quirk that
allows the user to blend into anything
they touch but they can only do it for
one object at a time this is definitely
not an old peak work since Invisible
Girl can just do that
all the time but a skilled hero or
villain could definitely make excellent
use of a camouflage quirk having someone
using a quirk like this in combination
with their own custom weapons like stain
does would be cool to see and that is
all I have time for in this video some
epic suggestions here thank you all
including a lot of the other great ones
that I couldn't get to oh and nock stock
who also suggested a quirk on Twitter
but I'm not sure if it was a serious
suggestion or a fade zero meme if you
want to read all the other suggestions
and add your own be sure to follow us on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
and a new question of the week will be
coming up soon so look out for that and
remember that your response might be
featured in a future video if you are
new to this channel don't forget to
subscribe and Detroit smash that
notification bell so you can be notified
whenever a new video is out as always
thank you all so much for watching and
until next time see us space Cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]